welcome to all farm
[Music]
oh
sh
London Bridge is falling down falling
down falling down London bridge is
falling down my fair lady build it up
with sticks and stones sticks and ston
Sticks and Stones build it up with
sticks and stones My Fair Lady
[Music]
sticks and stones will All Fall Down All
Fall Down All Fall Down sticks and
stones will all fall down my fair lady
build it up with wood and Clay Wood and
Clay Wood and Clay build it up with wood
and Clay My Fair Lady
[Music]
w a clay will wash away wash away wash
away wood and Clay will wash away my
fairly build it up with Iron and Steel
Iron and Steel Iron and Steel build it
up with Iron and Steel My Fair Lady
[Music]
Iron and Steel will bend and bow Bend
and bow Bend and bow Iron and Steel will
bend
I
[Music]
hold
I e
[Music]
nothing here B